[Music]
we've designed our game around head
shots let's uh put a
steel wall in front of this guy's head
it's gonna take one head shot for
blackbeard to kill them but it's gonna
take four headshots for
the opponent to kill you the only
utility that you bring
is being a dick to the defenders he is a
absolute
nightmare to fight against
this game is so [ __ ] on one hand he's
like a shield operator and
on another hand he's a whole lot more
dangerous
there are plenty of controversial
operators in rainbow six siege
alright ubisoft we need to talk about
lion
you've designed an operator that can
literally give your entire team
wall hacks if used correctly but they
buffed ella's scorpion the first 16
shots now have
lower recoil than it did previously and
uh there's a lot of controversy around
this
ace is super oppressive melusi i can
tell you melusi is super oppressive
and there's nothing we can do about it
but despite having some stiff
competition
blackbeard and his once impenetrable
face shield
might just be the worst of them all the
reason why blackbeard is as powerful as
he is right now
is that he can basically claim an entire
room by himself
with not really putting himself at any
disadvantage whatsoever blackbeard was
one of the first operators added to
siege after it launched back in may
2016. his initial kit included a
mind-blowingly powerful
800 hp face shield it basically
neutralized headshots and in a game
where a quick headshot can make or break
around
blackbeard's face shield proved to be a
problem pretty quickly
just think about it in every first
person shooter
you're trained to go for headshots as
often as possible
they're usually one-hit kills and in
siege where defenders are holding angles
they're usually holding them at the
height of the enemy's head
but blackbeard made that instinct a
liability imagine this situation you're
holding an angle blackbeard turns the
corner you go for the headshot
you hit his shield he shoots you and
you die the only reason you pick him is
to get kills for yourself
you don't contribute to the siege
gameplay whatsoever you don't breach
anything
you don't you know you don't use any
utility to counter any other utility
your only utility
is to win gunfights blackbeard
terrorized siege so much that players
demanded a nerf
and ubisoft listened balancing was his
pick ratio and win ratio was clearly
show that he is very powerful
the following changes is meant to
address two points blackbeard now has
two shields and can cycle
them with a q system of equipment
unequipping so instead of one shield he
now has two
but however the hp the shield has been
reduced from 800 to 150
so it's you can break the shield a lot
easier and the shield this durability is
displayed in the ui
of course that meant that blackbeard
could still lock down angles more than
once
and face-to-face engagements still
usually went in his favor
the opposing team's skill didn't really
matter they could be the best gamers in
the world but
headshots just didn't work blackbeard
basically had an extra life every single
round
so when i'm playing blackbeard what i'm
trying to do is hold down lines of sight
use his rifle shield to my advantage and
i'm basically asking people to peek me
i'm hoping that people will pick me
because
of the rifle shield i have an advantage
and i should win that gun fight
and people who decided to main
blackbeard found other ways to exploit
his nearly impenetrable headspace
if all you're exposing is your head well
that's protected by the shield and then
the wall
is protecting the rest of your body so
you basically become immortal
as a counter strategy you could try to
flank blackbeard or
film full of body shots but neither was
particularly effective
oh two coming two coming two last time
question when i'll kill them
oh behind
i'm watching train you with train i got
him
nice round opinions of blackbeard also
varied across ranks
copper players don't usually go for
headshots anyway but in the higher ranks
well great players go for headshots as
often as possible
and they found blackbeard extremely
frustrating
i just shotgunned this guy in the face
this game is so [ __ ] with my shotgun
this guy
let me kill him in an attempt to make
blackbeard more balanced ubisoft tried
all kinds of things and now he's been
nerfed so many times he's commonly
referred to as nerf beard because his
shield was nerfed down to 60 hit points
his bullet damage was nerfed and his aim
down sight time was nerfed which is
basically cyber bullying by ubisoft
blackbeard could no longer just run and
gun his way through a round with a riot
shield on his face
all of a sudden calling him op was kind
of inaccurate
and i feel like most of the operators
that have been released well
they have been overpowered when they're
released
and then they are toned down a bit and
they're toned down a bit
and then eventually they're fine in
blackbeard's case though
things were not fine all those nerfs
created a
new host of issues has he been nerfed a
lot
yes is he a well-designed operator
hell no players were once accustomed to
playing blackbeard and doing whatever
they wanted
now saw his mighty shield shatter in two
shots
blackbeard was nowhere near as broken as
he used to be
but ubisoft kept his speed and his armor
at medium
which gave his mains a reason to call
him underpowered
slowly but surely blackbeard's shield
the entire core of his character
became irrelevant all of a sudden his
entire identity as an operator was
gone forgive me for stating the obvious
but it's worth pointing out that
the shield is the only thing that
differentiates blackbeard
from the other operators in the game so
basically if the shield is now
crap then there is no point using
blackbeard you may as well
go and use near enough any other
operator thermite
thatcher sledge blackbeard doesn't have
a lot of utility
and when his shields were broken that
made sense but after the nerfs
it kind of meant that he wasn't worth
picking what it really seemed like
blackbeard needed was a rework
but what that rework should be or how it
would affect player bases of different
skill levels
was a question just as divisive as the
operator himself
we're having an issue where we have a
quite a big split between the casual
community and the competitive community
very competitive community want big
changes and they want them fast
and the casual community kind of want to
have the fun of the game in another
sense than we do
and it's not like blackbeard isn't fun
to play under the right circumstances
he is still a force to be reckoned with
you slap blackbeard on a
on a person with really good aim that
already is winning a lot of their
gunfights
and you're gonna have an absolute
monster but on the flip side
those right circumstances don't always
present themselves
he's really good at windows but other
than that i mean his head shows most the
time if you guys didn't know that if
you're not crouching his head is showing
and it only takes a few bullets to even
get through shield so
very good at window play he's very good
whenever you're playing on windows but
other than that he's not good at really
anything else
four years after his release blackbeard
remains one of the most controversial
operators in siege
history ubisoft keeps trying to find a
middle ground
they don't want blackbeard to be broken
again but they also don't want him to
feel
useless blackbeard is interesting
because we learnt
so much from his ability when he
launched
he was one of the strongest overpowered
operators we ever released
when he when he's fun to play against
he's overpowered as [ __ ]
and when he's on fun to play against his
weakest [ __ ] that's how
poor of a design he is whether you think
blackbeard is op
or useless these days we can all agree
on one thing
he's a perfect example of how important
balance is to a competitive game
and how a lack of balance can bring
chaos
to the scene slowly but surely
it's like a bird here that's never
happened before never seen just a bird
hang out at my window
sorry this is really distracting hello
bird what's up
do you want to hang out talk about
esports how do you feel about esports
bird
what's your favorite what's your
favorite cs go team bird
the [ __ ] doesn't give a [ __ ]